I don't consume a lot of the type of
content I produce
and I think it's really important to as
a base be doing critical thinking
epistemology how do we believe the
things we believe
Basics about the world
after that reading history economics
philosophy Etc
after that now we're getting into
current events I would mostly be looking
at consuming
um primary source reporting things like
Associated Press whatever I know
everybody will have a different list of
what counts there after that is when I'd
say indulge in some of the commentary
type stuff that I do
if you find that I'm thoughtful enough
to make it into that but I'm very open
and really what I try to do on my show
often is in being that at the top of the
pyramid tell people there's all this
other stuff that should be forming your
foundation